hey guys Ryan right here dance ever here
dance Seibert has finally made his
return thank you Dan
thank you it's been a while Oh in a
while okay it's sucked I'm gonna just
masturbate to you and not actually due
to the real thing with you you know what
I mean so we're gonna watch trailer
today for Halo 2 I would love it if you
stopped halo 2 anniversary opening
cinematic trailer it it's just halo
let's [ __ ] [ __ ] the talking
[ __ ] mm-hmm
letting Gor love it you are one of our
most treasured instruments long have you
led your fleet with honor and
distinction
but your inability to save god Hayden
Wow looks so cool
doing the great journey shall begin but
when it does you shall be left behind
gentlemen we're lucky to have you back
maybe has lost one of his best produce
delivery of our battle Master Chief
defend this nation what exactly am I
looking so this is what my father found
the profit of the bread is planning to
activate halos are you sure oh damn
everything just looks so fun good
oh wow
please [ __ ] is awesome what you know
foundational disorient
the prophets have betrayed us he leaves
the coachman sleek to earth they will
send a chance to stop him
I need a weapon
we're going in
this is so exciting
without a destination solution
do they live [ __ ]
time I went to Mass I heard that song
did what mass you didn't edit what every
time I walked in the doors oh I think
you're generalizing an entire genre of
music okay Dan dude holy crap the
updated effects are totally adding great
pleasure to my being right now those
perhaps a weird sentence I've ever known
you put together but it looks fantastic
it looks amazing it's phenomenal it
looks like movie yeah it really it looks
like they said cinematic trailer and
that is what we [ __ ] diría scenario
ramadhir we know is a very less famous
cousin anytime you see Master Chief it's
like goddamn uh-huh be this guy in some
fashion I just don't want the armor I
just I don't really want I I'm probably
not gonna do very well with pushing a
bomb into a space yep that's fine that's
not my thing but I'll wear the armor
yeah like ride a motorcycle right did
you look like the [ __ ] but Master Chief
is just so [ __ ] cool and I love I
just love everything about this trailer
man Neil Blomkamp who's addicted like
district 9 in Elysium it's like he
totally his films like awesome because
they [ __ ] look like halo because
there was the source of his inspiration
I watched halo a lot here's my movies
anyway guys thank you for telling me
that trailer was out if you're new to
the chanel you can subscribe to the reel
rejects where we keep it ar e l real
film reel get it no one on YouTube does
that but us mm-hmm and you can check out
dance cyber channel is gaming channel
that's right not gagging channel gaming
channel some of you guys are getting
that confused I don't think anyone
giving that confuse and I'm trying to
protect you I haven't got a single
message like that okay dan can you also
check out more of my videos
someone told me I should start saying
that to you guys so yes check out more
of my videos I think this is called
plugging yeah plugging more content we
did five nights at Freddy's on my
channel that's right that one in it yeah
we got a plug another video and that's
the video we're choosing we played it
together
check that shisn't it out he's terrible
at it hook it and shoutouts
I think I'm caught up on all the
shoutouts
now here's what I also know oh I am NOT
caught up but all the shots I know I
probably miss some people probably just
a lot so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts find the link in
the description box below if you want a
shout-out and then put a shout-out
request down at the Facebook speech yeah
and did you or get this yeah Robert
DeNiro you know